Travis Kelce joining it's the Chiefs
tight end did you watch the NBA Finals
Travis yes I was actually at games three
and four in Cleveland
Oh where did you sit the game three I
was just around midcourt on the floor
and games where I was right across from
the Cavs bench who did you sit other
celebrities there who just sit next to
other celebrities no I don't think I
wasn't around any other celebrities but
there was every football team within
about a two-hour drive radius of
Cleveland was in the building but for
both games all right but being from Ohio
are you a Cavs fan oh yeah
Cleveland Ohio at that I mean yeah I'm
from the east side of Cleveland I've
been in cats fanatic since I was a kid
back when I could name and starting five
you've never even heard us try me
let's start with Terrell Brandon Bobby
Sura Danny Ferry Tyrone Hill and well I
guess you know who Shawn Kemp was but
you probably didn't know that's pretty
good that's pretty good how would you
fare though have you met LeBron um
unfortunately no I have no I have not
met the king hopefully one day I will I
know he he I think he I think I heard
somebody say he pick me up at Fantasy
one year and I held him out but I think
that's the that's the only relationship
that I have with them is through fantasy
football how would you do on the
basketball court you probably could have
got some run with the Cavaliers good
yeah I mean I'm not gonna you know I'm
not gonna say too much but I think that
I could have probably helped him out a
lot more than that some of the efforts
some of the effort that I saw on the
floor especially that last game now the
worst thing we can say about
professional athletes is you quit right
yeah I mean that's got to be the worst
thing for sure okay but how do we know
when did the Cavs quit in Game four I
don't think they quit I think it was
[Music]
yeah I think you
I think it was demoralizing how the
Golden State Warriors just kept hitting
three after three bucket after bucket
and we could make or I don't think it
was necessarily quitting I think it was
just the energy got low because of how
how good the Warriors really are what's
the worst that you ever like the most
helpless you ever felt on a football
field when you're facing the team the
most helpless
it was probably my first or second year
when we were playing Denver um and it
was like everything that we did it was a
fumble it was a false start on offense
some type of penalty and we couldn't get
anything going we got blue out at home
unlike Christmas or something like that
and I just remember sitting there like
man we cannot do anything at all correct
and we're I mean but the story we told
we ended up getting our tail look he's
Travis Kelce the Chiefs tight end
joining us Dan Patrick showed you get
Alex Smith they're going away a parting
gift you know I didn't but now that you
mention it I probably should send the
guys something for uh for everything
he's giving me in my career yeah but
what do you get him that's the thing
what do you get a guy like that who just
got the the contract he finally deserves
I just I don't know it's gonna have to
be something creative I'm not sure does
he have one of your jerseys
no but I don't think I don't think Alex
is a big Jersey guy I don't think he's a
big Jersey I think he I think something
like a bobble head or something like
that like a trip with his kids somewhere
be something he's more so going for his
big family guy he got a great contract
you know maybe you could use some good
teammates so maybe if maybe you could
send yourself there due to the Redskins
that'd be a nice gift for for Alex no I
mean I like I love Kansas City so I
think I think I'm set over here and he's
got some good tight ends over there he's
got Vernon and Jordan Reed too very
athletic athletic tight ends I mean I
think I think he's good in the tight end
room over there best
in the NFL is who Travis Kelce myself my
god just I personally I I take that in
trying and try and make that a
definitive answer every single year I
know I've been upping questions with
Groff the past couple years and that's a
very deserving for garance a hell of a
player but this year I mean obviously
I'm always trying to fill one up and
take it to the next the next level all
right but so Gronk and you considered 1a
1b or you're both tied whatever it might
be
who are some of the other tight ends
that you look at and go you know what
they belong in the conversation
well the Super Bowl champion Zach Ertz
I'm a guy that that missed a couple
games might not have the year-ending
stats that me and Grogg have had over
the years but i think zach is somebody
that is very productive runs great
routes and else's team win every single
week him Delanie Walker a guy named Greg
Olson no-burn Carolina has been doing it
for years it's unfortunate to see him
get banged up last year but I mean the
list really goes on Jason wouldn't last
years or his last year shout out to him
for for moving on and and and and
everything that he's taught me in my
career through just watching but I think
there's a lot of great tight ends that
that kind of don't get the respect that
they deserve how does it what's it feel
like when Patrick mahomes throws throws
you the football with a little steam on
it shocking and I've learned that over
the past couple weeks I think that he
can hum it man he can get it on you
quick and it's right out of your break
right on time so I mean it's it's fun
learning and then growing with with 1-5
right now and I think it's going to be
an amazing season this year all right
really I really feel the energy from it
the difference of catching a pass from
him and Alex Smith is one I mean I got
to get into a game and really feel it I
mean I think alex is a top tier
quarterback just like I think Patrick
can be and
obviously I've caught a lot of footballs
from Alex Smith and I don't know I'm
just one of those things where I'll just
have to kind of feel it out in the game
I don't necessarily have that answer for
you right now I know you're joining us
on behalf of Cigna explain this to me
because I like you were it's talking
about the safe use of opioids for pain
management
so yes explain what what the campaign is
all about here well there's a there's an
estimated 2.5 million Americans
suffering from the substance use
disorder related to prescription opioid
pain relievers and that's and that's a
big number in America it's a huge number
in it I don't think people are as aware
as they need to be about arm call
everyone could be affected by this I
mean one in five people that are
prescribed just a 10-day prescription of
these pain medicines these pain
relievers are at risk of a long term use
and that's not the that's that should
not be the goal going into it is being
on pain relievers for a long term so I
teamed up with Cigna Cygnus driving this
this platform for us and I think it's
what it's doing is it's it's creating
awareness and it's creating a
conversation that people need to have
with their doctors about pain relievers
and and how series of an issue it can be
in the long run you can text help with
pain to five seven nine to receive a
list of questions that you can ask your
health care provider along with the link
to other helpful resources how do you
deal with pain the just like I said I
I'm certainly football is something that
you know you're gonna deal with some
discomfort in terms of injury and in
pain week to week I mean it varies and
when to that I have a very good
relationship with the physician the team
physician the doctor my health care
provider it within the Chiefs and we
always have a plan you know I don't like
being on pain medicine for more than a
couple days more than a week it's just
something that I've been
unable to educate my cellphone and
unfortunately know that there's there's
there been people around me that have
got hooked on these things and have been
using them for a very long time and I
don't think one is good for your health
and two it's just it's it's scary road
to go down and knowing that I've seen
friends and teammates go down that road
I think it's a it's in me to kind of
broaden that awareness that you know
this is a very serious serious epidemic
you know it's strange that we we look at
football different than any other sport
like it almost like we don't blame you
whatever you use to play yeah that's
it's scary and it can become kind of
accepting that that football players
have one of very high pain tolerance but
to also that that they are almost like
they're needing of these pain but like
relievers and that's a there are there
are other healthy alternatives something
that you just have to go and talk to
your doctor about and it's talk to your
health care provider and make sure that
you're on a plan to keep you away from
the long term use it's great to catch up
with you will hopefully talk to you
during the regular season and good luck
in this upcoming season
I appreciate your day it's almost fun
run Thank You Travis
that's a Travis Kelce joining us on
behalf of Cigna for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]